la séance est ouverte
le contredion analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué
appelle-t-il des observations
il n'y en a pas le procès verbal et donc
adopté sous les réserves d'usage
la parole est à Monsieur Henri cavanel
pour une mise au point un sujet un vote
de la parole merci monsieur le président
lors du scrutin numéro 233 portant sur
l'article 7 du projet de loi de finance
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
pour 2023 ma collègue Nathalie Delattre
souhaitait s'abstenir je vous remercie
merci Madame Goulet ensuite pour une
mise au point
oui dans hier sur le scrutin 233 et de
l'article 7 je souhaitais voter contre
et j'ai été inscrite en votant pour donc
je demande à une rectification d'auto
plus cohérente que j'avais aussi voté
les amendements de suppression
et enfin Madame bonfontite de ça veut
aussi dire une déclaration
le vote le scrutin public 233 je
souhaitais m'abstenir